leur discipline le tir sportif à 25
mètres le pistolet vitesse exige
précision rapidité et adresse il demande
immobilisme et dynamisme dans le geste
pour réaliser des séries de 5 tirs en 8
6 et 4 secondes
médaille d'or à Tokyo en 2020 plusieurs
fois champion du monde d'Europe et de
France Jean qui campois vise une
nouvelle qualification pour Paris numéro
1 mondial cette année trois fois
champion d'Europe Clément Bessaguet est
déjà assuré de sa participation ils sont
amis dans la vie et partenaires dans
l'entraînement
le fait d'être en baston tous les jours
et de pouvoir se confronter directement
au quotidien ça nous aide à progresser
et à se préparer pour les compétitions
et de d'avoir de la confrontation sur
les compètes et au quotidien tous les
jours on se tire la boue en fait et on
fait toujours des matchs parce qu'on
fait tout un des matchs c'est notre
façon de t'entraîner on fait beaucoup de
matchs pour voir un peu de notre niveau
aussi et
inconsciemment un petit peu se tient à
la bourre ce qu'on voit combien l'autre
a fait comme il nous a fait un coup
c'est lui qui gagne du coup c'est moi et
c'est vrai que c'est
ultra motivant quoi
que l'entraînement ça représente à peu
près 3 à 4 heures par jour de tir pur
donc c'est à peu près 300 à 400
cartouches et après il y a toute la
partie physique aussi qui vient
compléter l'entraînement technique et
tir ça va être du gainage et
essentiellement et après le cardio est
bien complété parce que nous la
difficulté c'est de réussir à tirer avec
un rythme cardiaque
très bas enfin justement compète avec le
stress il monte et c'est la difficulté
c'est de réussir à le faire descendre
donc le cardio il nous aide à améliorer
cette cet aspect là et d'arriver à tirer
le plus détendu possible
depuis le jeu de Tokyo j'ai un contrat
pro en fait où je suis à la douane
maintenant donc il me permet vraiment de
me consacrer enfin c'est vraiment 100%
dans le tir et je le vois dans mes
résultats maintenant parce que ben là ça
fait depuis Tokyo du coup je m'entraîne
tous les jours que j'ai pu la fatigue
que j'avais avant et mon travail etc et
je vois que mon niveau monte et surtout
en régularité
les jeux de leur fait deux fois c'est
c'est une super expérience dans le sens
où elle a fait du sport des jeux c'est
quelque chose extraordinaire les avoir
l'année prochaine ici c'est c'est
vraiment une super opportunité pour
faire rayonner le tir sportif pour faire
rayonner la France pour faire rayonner
notre sport enfin c'est c'est
extraordinaire
c'est un rêve c'est clair et moi j'y
vais pour gagner comme à chaque
compétition que je fais j'y vais pour
gagner et de toute façon je cocherai tir
tant que je sais que je peux gagner je
vis pour la compète quoi c'est j'adore
ça et j'adore pouvoir me dire que je
peux gagner et que je dois tout mettre
en place pour gagner quoi et c'est ça en
fait c'est un petit plus dans le dans le
challenge mais c'est clair que de gagner
de gagner un Châteauroux et ça serait ça
serait énorme quoi reste pour le tenant
du titre à décrocher cette deuxième
place pour l'équipe de France l'objectif
de la fédération est simple la médaille
d'or que le meilleur gagne
[Musique]